computer load up celery man please yes
as I always like to say to Paul Rudd's
are better than one and with Netflix's
latest living with yourself which I
thought could be about me because I'm so
alone they truly deliver in this video
we'll be taking a deep dive into the
ending and unlocking the key to
happiness okay maybe not that last part
but we'll cover some equally cool things
like a lactating paul rudd so get ready
to escape from your cellophane graves
because here we go
the final episode begins with miles
having been captured by the fda who were
able to trace his call from episode 2
when he informed them of human cloning
violations committed by the top happy
spa and although the series might seem
to be about a man struggling to balance
life with a new and improved clone at
its core it's a story of a man
struggling with what it means to be
truly happy in Episode one we meet our
completely miserable protagonist Miles
Elliott everything just seems to go
wrong for him he's not respected at work
kills a fly and says you're welcome
because the world sucks it's better to
be dead than alive boxes head smashes a
lightbulb with his fists and even keeps
rescheduling an appointment with the
fertility clinic he's so miserable about
life he doesn't want to bring a new one
into the world but the irony is that's
exactly what he does just not in the way
he foresaw after getting a
recommendation from a co-worker miles
takes $50,000 money that was supposed to
go toward paying for him and his wife's
fertility treatment to the top happy spa
a spa which supposedly can make those
who go through its process happy again
and when you think about it as spa is a
perfect place for this to happen
a place that's meant to make you relax
and where sometimes you can get a happy
ending but miles his experience is far
from happy before going under there's a
problem with the gas and miles wakes up
in a makeshift grave in the middle of
the forest only to venture home and find
a new and improved clone of himself
living his life his happiness was never
cured
it was just artificially created and
replaced now if you played close
attention when miles is being put under
one of the last images he sees is of a
unicorn a mythological creature that
actually appears in various forms
several times throughout the series like
here in Episode four the Unicorn is a
symbol of miles as happiness something
he wants to achieve but is unattainable
or at least it's unattainable until he's
earned it when miles goes and visits his
half-sister and laments about his plight
she says what is arguably the most
important line in the entire series I
don't get it
why can't I be happy for once because
you didn't earn it like most of us in
society we want the easy solution to our
problems the quick fix and that's what
miles does pays the 50,000 to get
instant happiness but the process goes
wrong and we find out it never cured the
real miles if he is to truly find
happiness now he must earn it and it's
only until he goes through the journey
of self-discovery that he finally
obtains it in Episode five we get a
glimpse of miles his life five years
before the events of Episode one he's a
completely different person he is the
epitome of a great husband
caring taking his wife to their future
home and is excited about life and maybe
will come in the mean time let's make
this a home this is completely opposite
from what we've seen so what happened
over the course of those five years well
the show never explicitly shows us but
we can surmise that miles and Kate's
dreams of the future never turned out
the way they had planned miles becomes
complacent with his job their plan to
have a child never really pans out and
the monotony of living in the suburbs
seems to have gone to the both of them
it was never Kate's plan to live in the
suburbs either this was miles as vision
and that vision of the perfect future
has all but failed causing eventual
resentment between the two of them the
eventual stealing of the credenza an
object which symbolizes both Kate and
miles as relationship and settling down
becomes something that is hated by the
two of them miles continually bumps into
it and asked when they're gonna get rid
of it
even Kate comes to resent it deciding to
give it up I think I'm gonna get rid of
that credenza it isn't until the last
episode that the two miles take an axe
to it destroying this idea of what a
relationship is supposed to be that
something new conformed in its place
the eventual joining of the three in
raising a new family
when Myles escapes the f-d-a at the
beginning of the last episode he rushes
to his wife to tell her how wrong he was
the whole time I love this shot of the
column separating the two of them the
wrote this season kate has expressed how
much she hates it and in this shot it
acts as a barrier between the two just
like there was a barrier within their
relationship but Martha's journey has
shown him what was wrong this whole time
I want to apologize for everything I've
been so selfish just so focused on me
that I forgot about you us what's
important our family our future family
miles needed to realize this about
himself before he could find his own
happiness again as his sister said
earlier he needed to earn it but this
comes crashing down when he finds out
that the new miles slept with his wife
and miles his journey can't be complete
without resolving things with his other
half he goes in with the intention of
killing his clone but can't go through
with it perhaps the most heartbreaking
is this line from miles as clone you got
to wake up next to her every day for ten
years all I've got her memories and
those aren't even real I just wanted
your life
I loved her life which is ironic because
the old miles didn't love his life
something the miles clone loves so much
he was willing to kill himself for it
it's only through seeing the loved clone
miles had for his wife that it holds a
mirror to his own selfish ways and
speaking of his wife kate arrives to
find the two men having made up and
tells them of her pregnancy the thing is
because they share the same DNA it's
impossible to tell which one of them is
the father we never really find out how
this dynamic will work from
but it's heavily implied that the three
of them will raise the child together
with old mile saying we're gonna have a
baby while looking at both his wife and
the clone and this fits in with what
Harold says in Episode four that
marriage is a union of two souls
separated at birth but since miles was
split in two it will take the both of
them working together to complete this
union in a society where more and more
people suffer from depression and one in
which we're more connected than ever but
simultaneously alone living with
yourself raises important questions on
what it means to be happy so before you
invest 50k at the spa take a good look
at yourself what can you do to bring
happiness to those around you and maybe
just maybe you might find some yourself
thanks for watching this video please
make sure to give it a like and
subscribe with the Belon I come up with
new videos every week so you'll want to
stay tuned you can also follow me on
twitter at think story whitey and until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much